and um I was listening to what you're
saying and
everything felt all right until you said
you had a child
for me personally because I just think
to myself marriage is a hard work yes
marriage is a hard work and I think if
you've got a child to say like oh I need
to we need to go and find ourselves to
me it just seems like everything's just
going backwards like you're finding that
like you got married first rather than
find out about each other then get
married and have the child all I'm
thinking about is yeah you might be
great co-parents but I'm thinking to
myself is
marriage is hard work yeah it is and to
say like I'm gonna come back and revisit
it in another five years to me that's
just me personally it sounds weird yeah
especially as your traditional you're
supposed to work at it no like I said it
wasn't my choice that wasn't my choice
so obviously it's not my choice that he
feels like he's not ready to commit into
that role again and that's what I mean
but you married him and that's what I
was saying that it seems weird because
you married him and they never like
you're starting
backwards so what I'm saying is
obviously in my situation I could try
find a new partner or husband or
whatever to marry it's just this country
I don't think is it enables that does
that make sense everyone's everyone's
trying to be City girl or city life and
that doesn't it's not something that I
would do so I feel like in this culture
and this Society I'm not going to find
the man I want to marry and when I say
three years I say three four years you
could be even next year whatever but
it's more if he's ready when he's ready
where he is I might be at the stage
where we're ready to work it out again
yeah because that's what I find
interesting oh you know also can I just
sorry for cancer I just wanted to add
like listening to the whole story like
Auntie said it's it's like it's worked
backwards So within everything you've
said not once have I heard anything
about like your child how this impacts
your child and I'm not judging you for
that but that child has to live through
it and how does
she doesn't know that we're separated
I don't know but but the thing is the
thing is that's an assumption as your
daughter grit gets older she will notice
little things she will ask questions and
I think a lot of
relationship breakdowns don't ever
consider the children the children the
children don't choose to be here we
bring them here as adults and part of
being an adult is being responsible and
part of being responsible is making good
choices and making informed decisions
about the things that we do so I'm not
saying like your relationship is this or
that but what I am saying is a lot of
the time
um children are kind of pushed to the
side and it's me me me me me even within
the partnership that's why it doesn't
work because everybody's thinking about
themselves finding themselves doing
their thing
um you know exploring themselves
whatever
children are growing up in fragmented
families and then they have no Direction
no they might have a foundation but they
don't have any direction yeah
I think I think
it feels as if like we're putting their
ownness just on her so her not her
saying sorry not her so it's Soraya
saying that she wants to that's the time
apart is needed yeah he also feels the
exact same thing that she's feeling so
he also needs to take time about I do
honest I do think that a lot of people
sometimes get into relationships and
they've got like a a me mindset and that
will not help relationships yeah but I
really believe that there are certain
things you need to work on on your own
yeah before you can then be in you can
then come together with someone and
build a healthy relationships
sorry let me yeah let's finish for
example yeah say like say for example
say you've got like the things you've
been through previous Partners or
whatever if you do not work on that on
your own yeah you're going to enter a
new relationship and you're doing to
bring up all that baggage into this new
situation it doesn't help you it doesn't
help the child I don't like when people
think that you yes children are
important yes you do whatever works for
you for your child but I have friends
who've grown up where the moms have
stayed with the dads Because they stay
for the kids and the kids have grown up
and said you know I wish you left that
because because you could have gone and
been at home you could have been a
healthy a woman who sorted out sorted
out her life it's usually it's usually
because my mom the mom talks too much to
the kids you shouldn't know about
yourself
the moms no I see this again and again
and again like moms moms will demonize
the dad and like talk [ __ ] about the dad
and then and then say oh you should like
why why does a kid know that I did not
know that I disagree that the second and
the second and the second thing is I I
don't know her marriage I'm not saying
it's not his fault too I said but I said
the marriage yeah but I'm saying like
like for both people like if you have a
kid involved like what you need to
figure out yourself figure it out in one
Under One Roof no but I disagree I
disagree with that because I have again
out this is what I'm saying is stuff
that conversation I've had with people
who have actually been in these in these
real life situations I know I have
friends whose mums literally did not let
them know what's their dad what piece of
[ __ ] the dad was they grew up to see
what a disappointment their father was
and they were like their mum to know why
would she left I think that yes people
are important I think that it's I think
that yes you know you should create the
best environment for your child and blah
blah blah all that is great absolutely
yes cool whatever but sometimes being in
the same household is not the best
environment for your child you put your
kid at every single statistical
disadvantage they're more likely to run
away from home they're more likely to
drop out of school they're more likely
to be homeless they're more likely to
end up in prison there's a direct
correlation between single parent homes
and going to prison so you can you can
you can say okay okay you know there are
certain situations that are exceptions
sure but if there's not abuse there's
not cheating
why are you why are you doing that to
your kid I'm supposed to put your kid
first go ahead of yourself how many
parents from the panel
well I just wanted to say this as well
um to go back to what you said when you
said no people you've spoken to have
said now I wish you had left that or
whatever I wish you would expect it yeah
or separated but that means that there
were things that were going on yeah that
they could see and feel an experience
now how do they know what it would have
been like without having their dad in
the household I think it's fair for
children to grow up to make their own
decisions about especially their fathers
because I feel in society as women we
make a lot of decisions for our children
based on how we feel at the time and we
put our children at a disadvantage
and I think for myself I always say this
but my dad
the things that he's done for me I'm not
saying oh that's a perfect my dad's not
a perfect man but there's things my dad
has done for me that have given me
strength inner strength that I can't
explain to you I can only show you the
way that I operate
um so for you to say like they've said
why I can't why didn't you leave dad
there must have been something in the
household that they were experiencing
my mum would always tell me as a basic
rule when you're raising kids they never
see anything that goes on whether it's
decision making whether it's fighting
nothing happens in front of the kids and
I brought this point up before when I
talked about women having or losing
their power because a lot of women want
to be at the Forefront of relationships
now where they dictate things my mom
said a lot of the decisions made in the
household my dad looked like he was
making the decision when really she had
a lot of influence on how the decision
was made that's not because that she
wanted to be at the front is because she
knew how to play her role in that
relationship when my parents did fight
it was never in front of us because what
would happen is that kids are
opportunists they're going to have
favorites if you see your mum fighting
your dad most kids will gravitate to
their mum your dad naturally becomes a
demon in that in that kid's eyes so
parents show too much and women again
like Paul said love to talk a lot
they'll start saying he's doing this and
then you and the kid become best friends
and start talking about secrets in the
relationship how the hell is that kid
not going to grow up thinking the
devil's a piece of [ __ ] when the mom
vocalized every single problem she had
like the way she would to her best
friends
I like that though but I also said that
the situations that I cases that I know
cases where the parents that they didn't
know they grew up to know what had
happened in the house yeah grew up they
got there but my thing is still like I
still maintain the fact that there are
things that you need to work on by
yourself that you cannot do in a
relationship and I think that each
person each family is a case-by-case
situation every not every child it's not
a universal law or Universal rules or
rulebook of how to raise children and so
if in any situation you feel like you
know what the best thing for this child
knowing how my child is having emotion
my channels or whatever it is the best
thing for my child is that we go as we
go our sufferers and we can be healthy
parents and it's a healthy part before
the child
don't you think it's more mature to say
um I'm gonna figure out how to get along
with a man before before just breaking
up
the question was your child's life ever
in danger no no